delta variant of course it continues to
spread across the country
so the white house is all set to make
some sweeping changes to its covet
policy
today president biden is expected to
announce that
all federal workers and contractors
that's about 2 million people
will have to prove that they've been
vaccinated against covet or else have
regular cova testing
the administration is also making indoor
mask a requirement at federal buildings
in areas of high transmission for both
the employees and the visitors too
several major companies are also
introducing strict new vaccine policies
facebook and google
are now requiring all u.s based
employees to be vaccinated
if they want to come back to the office
unless they cannot do so for medical
reasons netflix is
also requiring vaccinations for all cast
members
and on-set crew for their u.s based
productions
we're joined now by nicholas thompson
the ceo of the atlantic good morning to
you nicholas when you hear about
facebook and google making these
requirements do you think
other companies will follow suit i think
a lot of companies are going to follow
suit
very quickly a lot of companies are
doing this i think one of the things
we've seen since the beginning of the
pandemic
is that the tech companies in general
have been ahead
of everybody else they were the first to
let employees start working from home
and that's partly because it's just
easier for them to take action and to
let all their employees work remotely
because they're just working over
computers so
i think we'll see again what we saw back
in march what are some of the legal
ramifications you could see with this as
you mentioned those are tech companies
so it's easy to do that work but what
about other companies that might say you
have to get mandated if you want to come
back in this building
well the law is fairly clear that you
can mandate
your employees get vaccinated as long as
you take
reasonable action to protect people
under the american disabilities act
or people with religious freedom
exemptions so the law is clear that you
can
do it now at some companies you might
get an employee backlash
you might in fact see that at the tech
companies where they have
a lot of libertarians they come a little
bit out of the counter culture
you can see it being a contentious issue
but i think
legally you're allowed to do it well
nick it's but it's a very competitive
workplace right now a lot of people are
having trouble finding workers do you
think that could factor in in terms of
what they're going to do
yes and no right in certain areas it
could be a disadvantage
to mandate that your employees get
vaccinated because maybe a large pool of
the people you want
don't want to get the vaccine in other
areas it could be an advantage
because people will feel a lot safer if
they know
that their colleagues are vaccinated i
also think that the tech companies are
taking a
bet that this will make it seem that
they have
moral leadership and this will help
their overall reputations
so they probably think it's a
competitive advantage but in other areas
it could work the other way well nick i
sure hope
other companies follow suit you know
people say they're confused
the cdc keeps changing or flip-flopping
and i think they pointed out the other
day
that the cdc isn't changing it's this
variant that has changed as science has
changed
and now we have to act accordingly so
how can
companies realistically enforce these
policies
it's hard to enforce right and what we
don't know from the tech companies
is whether they'll just say employees
must promise
they've been vaccinated or whether
they'll take a further step and say
employees must
send in their vaccination cards and
we'll verify them so
we'll get the details on that there are
certainly ways
of enforcing it and mandating it but
you're right it is a tricky thing to do
i think you are
also right that as the science changes
private companies can take action to
lead
in the response which is one of the
things we're seeing here yeah because
employees can say look
you know you can't force me to do this
and i think you're right you can't
enforce employees
to do that but i think companies have
the right to say i want to keep uh
my my employees safe so you can't work
here
right and so what facebook and google
are going to do and this is partly why
they can go first
is that they can say okay fine if you
refuse to get vaccinated
and you can do your job completely
remotely and not get in contact with
your other employees
which is true for a fairly significant
number of their employees
then they'll let the employee work at
home so they have an easier time doing
it
then say a company where everybody has
to come into the office
and if somebody says then hey i refuse
to get vaccinated
you then have a really hard choice of
whether you let that employee
go or change your policies so it's
easier
for tech companies to make that choice
right now
all right nick thompson it certainly is
the beginning of a conversation that a
lot of companies will be having thanks a
lot